[Music]
welcome back everybody to a phenomenal
episode of the careful boys we are super
blessed today to have Jason chenny back
in the okay Jason
chenny he's here he's finally here I
just want to say that if you roll the
tape back you you when you said oh
welcome back to it and then you went you
did a sigh it wasn't a good delivery
it's not it wasn't
me he doesn't really feel the
authenticity take two he's like welcome
back everybody to a sick ass episode of
The
Care why you do that why would you do
that again man the second that was
pretty good though we are wasting
precious seconds of great content Jason
CH Jason chedy wants to feel the love
from you Anthony he just thinks that
you're fake ass influencer here and he
wants you to be authentic yo why could
you be authentic man dude if you watch
all the videos in the last like half
year people would start to think maybe
Joe doesn't like me really ien nuh I
don't know dude keeps on throwing shade
you know when somebody keeps throwing
shade in the room that means they have a
crush on you yeah us it means they're
flirting and honestly I think that's how
Joe shows love dude is that it I think
how people feel in the comments I
complimented anyone cool so here's the
OTR top how he shows lust that's very
true now I'll [__] that [__] out of you
yeah did say it in a wonderful way what
is an impression that people might have
of you but it's actually the opposite
and this goes for everybody oh [__] what
do you believe is an impression that
people have you but it's actually the
opposite I don't think I I'm people
think I'm I know I look pretty straight
edge but like why you space it up each
word is very dangerous a space bar bro
is my delivery
okay it's it's straight edge is it one
word or two words I don't know actually
whatever the same sentence I think
people usually say straight edge when
they're no I like no I like it the way
you said it actually people say it in
one breath like straight edge are you
talking about like drug free straight
edge no just like you know like I I know
people think I i' um go to church maybe
do you know what I mean like goodie two
shoes yeah Goody Two Sho do you go to
church oh okay I I did yeah you look
goody two shoes yeah but maybe that's
you seem really like goody good you're
wholesome I think you're a very
wholesome guy but I'm like I like I go
to church but I also you know sin a
little bit what kind of sins do you
participate in what's what's wrong with
that image though confess are you trying
to be like I'm actually a bad boy no I'm
not a bad boy pay me as some good boy no
I oh like if I so for example if I like
drink or like smoke a cigarette people
go
that's not the Jas that I know yeah
that's what like they're disappointed
they'll be like oh I didn't know you did
that disappointed I just I want to be a
human as well I like to uh Sin Sin a
little bit sometimes what gives people
that impression you think who who's
doing that the fans or just friends or
like yeah or like just call um friends
cuz you're very wholesome yeah I try to
be you know but uh I try to be I think
you just are I have intrusive thoughts
yeah everybody does but you do yeah you
do look wholesome and I feel like you
behave in a wholesome way I try to
though yeah but if you try to isn't that
the don't people have but if I [__] up
and then you you disappointed now oh
that's why yeah want you to be
disappointed if I [__] up I see what you
mean yeah you know what I mean like I'm
doing my best but then that guy is
[__] up all the time why don't you
say [__] to that
guy held to a higher standard that makes
sense I don't want a higher standard
expect nothing expect the worst thing
you know when I expect nothing from you
is when you start sticking your Tong
tongue out like that you go yeah you go
trying to be all like perverted and
stuff that means expect nothing from him
yeah I go man this guy is crazy dude
that's what I think what
man you stick your tongue out you
telling me you don't do that that's like
one of your signature moves yeah you
always do that I would never do
[Laughter]
that okay let's go let's go go to a
thing okay let's go let's not talk about
the tongue thing talk about something
else is that somebody else in the room
oh my God is that not a thing you
like you okay Ryan and then
you yeah too okay Ryan's turn Ryan he's
he has The Paton to CH to give to people
I think I think one thing that I think
mine's sort of similar but not in like
the oh what's your thing I wouldn't say
like wholesome but I think like people
will just think I'm very good yeah like
but he's a very good bad boy I think
it's the same thing yeah but what what's
like a thing that you would do that you
think that is like opposite to what yeah
I'm always surprised whenever people
will be like uh if someone and I hear
this a lot randomly people be like oh I
can't imagine you cussing and I'm like
are you I say I [__] cuss all the
time no now it sounds like you're trying
to cuss maybe it's like the
delivery maybe it's like the delivery
doesn't sound like as abrasive if I'm
doing it it's very C I don't I don't
hear it when you curse I think sometimes
sometimes when I cuss I go why do I put
[__] right there I need to say that
you know but like when you curse I don't
even notice it yeah see that's the thing
I that I all throughout my life I've
heard that randomly will people be like
oh but you you wouldn't cuss you don't
even say [__] or [__] and I'm like what
the [__] [__] are you talking about
stop trying to press me dude it's not
organ because majority of the time I'm
only really cussing comedically like I'm
not like serious or mad so it doesn't
sound like the same maybe but that's one
thing that I'm always like what you
think I'm like like good it's like weird
I'm like that too something I will
sometimes I will say like a dirty weird
like a sexual thing or like a [__] up
thought but people go oh he's a clean
comedian I was like I said [__] 17
times ju like 23 times and they're like
oh he's a clean
guy you say it does feel clean though
yeah it does yeah but like the [__] up
like it doesn't sound a BRAC it doesn't
sound like it still sounds like you did
not say any bad words you know why
because because when I say [__] juice
you know the [__] juice I'm describing
is with like angel dust and sunshine n
it's not the bad [__] you don't look
like a potty mouth yeah you're so yeah
you look so like well-kept yeah I TR
yeah but yeah maybe just perception like
sometimes you see a guy that is you know
more grungy and they say like you know
vagina and they're like oh this is a
dirty dirty
guy yeah if you say like if you say
vaginal that sounds dirtier than saying
like [__]
juice cuz you sound like you know what
you're talking about like you're a
doctor but I think for for me too is
like I like when people are like dude
you're [__] dark cuz like that's
always been my humor I think but then
like not your skin tone huh
yeah but like before I think like people
assume that I'm always like light so
then if I say one thing that sounds dark
they're like yo you have like a secret
dark side and it's like no it's not
secret that's mainly my thing it's like
that's that's primarily how I see [__]
but like so was it more hurtful when
we're all here and we're like dude
Ryan's wild but no I like that cuz
that's funny to me but then like people
who are being serious and they're like
yo I think you have like a hidden dark
agenda it's like no that's my main
agenda this Earth You know when Ryan was
posting all those crazy ass fake news on
the I oh so good said Ryan a DM I was
like I wouldn't be surprised motorcycle
club I was like I wouldn't be surprised
if you're Satoshi
nakam for real though I was like you
probably invented [__] Bitcoin you
know think about R he's [__]
mysterious too bro that's why you're
you're you're kind of mystical like it's
like do you think I'm mysterious because
there's something else I'm not saying or
that I'm just like cuz I feel like I'm
pretty open no you are open you're just
mysterious cuz you never know what I'm
going to be right behind
you cuz you know why you're mysterious
cuz I I walked out of the bathroom today
and I see you bent over spreading your
cheeks and farting right in front of me
wow me [__] laugh harder than I have
in a very long out and everything no
because this is what happened so like
normally when Nick goes to the bathroom
that's mysterious bro normally when Nick
goes to the bathroom I think of like
what's the prank I can do on Nick and
then usually I've been bringing the the
symbol drum symbols next to the bathroom
and then I just wait with the drum
sticks and then he comes out and go okay
he did that to me one time today this
morning scared the [__] out of me and it
did to Jason but then this time he went
and I didn't realize he was there so it
was too late I ran really quick I had
the sticks but I didn't move the drum so
I was just there with no drum and I was
like oh sh he's going to come out what
do I do and then the anticipation of
waiting for it made my build
up so then when he opened the door I
just I just stuck my ass out and I
farted on him yeah and I walked right in
dud yeah dude you know what can we give
it up for yeah improv that was such a
good it was a strong choice and I was
upset that you didn't get that one on
film cuz that was the best one I think
of the night yeah he liked it he wanted
to shake my hand after he liked it so
much but also I'm I'm going to go to the
bathroom at home I'm not going to go to
the bathroom
anymore like for the rest of the night
there's no way you go so much much yeah
dude I drink a lot of water like six
times a
session but it's quick though you guys
serving you all kinds of beverages then
but yeah that's mine is just like the
like the dichotomy of like you
know I think I'm very prideful about
being dark I like it what's the question
is the people what the people think of
you and then they got you all wrong yeah
it's like an impression that they have
of you but you're quite the opposite
like like a example would be like what's
an impression you're surprised to hear
like whoo that's what you think of me
damn yeah about you so for me like for
example um I'm not a 911
dener nah you're just joshing dude
you're just messing around but for some
reason there's a
suppression that I am that was true
no now the surprise is better surprise
is
better um I I have made a comment on
here before a long time ago that I love
being on JK because um prior to being
more consistent on J AK most people who
see myself on social media they only see
Dance videos and that's such a unique
expression I don't get to talk and I'm
almost like mirroring the vocal
expression of like the singer or the
artist or the music choice and usually
my my choice of music is like ethereal
Spacey chill or like kind of cool
whatever and that's just sometime that's
not not who I am but that's just one
side of who I am where clearly I have a
completely different side maybe it's the
Gemini me but I a very different side so
it was only when like I started coming
on JK all the time that people started
really learning about a completely
different version of me that wasn't
different it was just the other version
of me that I didn't get to express
through dance he switching sign like a
Gemini yeah so if you only saw my dance
stuff you'd be [__] thrown off if you
were chilling in a room with me which
actually anytime I traveled like
International or whatever and like
students met me or I hung out with other
teachers or organizers in different
places they would only learn about me
through my Dance Artistry so when I
would hang out with them and and
suddenly I'm like the I don't know the
hardest Drinker in the room and partying
hella hard and stuff like that or making
hella jokes that's like a whoo this is
crazy it's fun it's it's cool but it's
just way different than we expected
what's the what's the perception that
they have of you as when it's just
dancing if it's just Dan is it like I
thought you were just a serious artist
or something Ryan how would you explain
if you just saw the in it is just the
dancing what what kind of stereotype
does he have I think like based on Dance
you would think Anthony's just more like
earthy and more mystical because a lot
of the [__] you create has that Vibe
even the dialogue that you write for
kjas doesn't sound like something you'd
ever say in real life but you're able to
put yourself there to make it I think
people expect that that's just how you
are normally but they don't they
underestimate and think that you're
you're going to a place to make these
materials you're not always in it so
then when you meet him you're like wao
you're a lot more like a abrasive than I
thought you're kind of like you're
taking shots you know what I mean like
you're kind of like a fast talking more
clever uh person yeah and you're not
afraid to like just say [__] [__] for
fun and then I think that's what catches
people off guard and they're like oh
your words are not as like composed on a
scroll as I thought they would
be well said yeah that [__] kind ofs but
that's because that's when I first met
him I was like I wasn't sure how to take
him because when I first met you you
really you're like a puncher when when
you talk and I was like is he trying to
hurt my feelings or is he just playing
and then I'm like oh that's his [__]
way of like oh you're you're good now
you know what I mean and I'm like I get
it but I can see how someone might be
like he's making fun of me yeah you know
what I mean cuz it seems like he's
punching
down and that's not fun also because
he's taller high tower yeah dude you're
[__] it's like why are you punching
down fun of me dude come on punching us
all from his Penthouse I was like come
on yeah but I can see that yeah popcorn
Joe I think that uh if people follow
this show or if they've seen me for many
years they're seeing me at a playful
relaxed state so they don't see me when
I'm in deep thought of things that I do
outside of here when I'm serious and I
have to put my business Joe on so I
think that they might be you know maybe
waiting for me like on a business call
to just be like and you know I might be
talking to a person that's from a bank
or whatever and then they know who I am
and I might just maybe they're just
waiting for me to ask them if they've
got their dick sucked lately MH or
something you know and I know that
they're like they're like for they're
waiting for it and I don't do it and I
feel like I'm a disappointment sometimes
cuz like this is my space to be like
just ah you know like and I get it all
out here here and then sometimes I'm
going back and I'm like yeah and I have
to be like serious like normal and then
so I'm not always this way do you like
it to be normal well I think my version
of normal is probably still not normal
oh okay but I'm much more controlled in
certain situations like I'm much more
self-aware than I put off but I think
this is the freedom that I get where I I
can relax and play and enjoy and and be
with you guys and and then say bizarre
[__] and then I go back into my
sometimes boring like normal business
situations and then I do run into people
that have seen JK [__] before and then I
feel like for them it's a shock cuz
they're like well you're Norm you're
normal like like I thought you were
going to ask me you know what my
favorite top five porn was but
you yeah had it ready dude I had my top
five ready I put a lot of thought into
the
list cuz I'm working with a lot of
different professionals from like that's
true loan officers business Bankers you
know all like guys in like regular 9
to-5 that are like hey even though you
put a suit on like I know you go home
and [__] watch JK news you know like
and then so I think for them there's
this whole like when you're on
camera it's just you're just this guy
but then like you're someone else like
here or I don't know yeah yeah I totally
see that man I I definitely felt that
too like just being out of here and
chilling with you and then remember when
we went to go eat Korean barbecue at one
time like in the very beginning when we
first were here mhm and they both of us
at the same that's right Joe was just
talking about normal
things oh yeah once again I was like I
had my top five list ready dude was that
the little yeah because Joe is just like
hey so how's it going how's everything
with you like what are you [__]
trying to make me say right now trap set
up off me dude I thought he you know
like when someone [__] with your food
and they try to talk to you to distract
you so you play it wait a minut he's
about to roast me right now I'm in this
[Laughter]
Bui I've lost that much trust
with no it's just in the beginning
you're just like oh [__] it's such a
huge change right I think that's I think
that's the differences that I I actually
use this space as a as a place to just
let off to go right and then but in in
real life that's why I can be super
serious but I've been told in the past
where like me and Bart are similar but
my swings are way wider like like Bart
does have his camera Bart but he does
have his like off camera Bart but he's
like more chill and it's subtle whereas
like I'm like either really out there
and bizarre or I'm really
serious that's true I don't think it's
like a I don't think you're like um
playing a character on camera though I
think it's you it's actually you just
just a different expression because yeah
you understand it but I'm more but I
think people don't expect me to be
controlled cuz I'm so out of control so
then when I am in control of my thoughts
and my like you know what I'm saying and
[__] is just they're probably like so
when you going to start rubbing your
dick in front of me you know like like I
could see it like I also can't imagine
you outside of here like going somewhere
and just being like what are you mean
like that I can't imagine that ever
happening you know what I mean like that
like that volume and level like at home
oh yeah yeah but just like to a person
that's not understanding the context I
can't imagine you like forcing that on
him what
what about you yeah gay what do you say
gays side I know that's a tough question
I don't even know what people even think
about me oh please no seriously like
what the [__] he's so amazing he's such
a fighter he's so strong funniest guy
when people refer to me as a fighter I
get annoyed by that cuz I'm like dude I
[__] am not a fighter that's not what
I did I didn't do that I only I tapped
my toe in there I'm definitely not a
fighter cuz I feel like it's like ah
dude I people associate you with certain
traits as like being a fighter and I'm
like dude I that was so long ago I can't
even like think of myself as a fighter
and I'm like n I'm definitely was not a
fighter dude that's like one of them huh
does anyone think you're mean before you
like meet them and talk to them yeah a
little bit I'm like dude yeah I'm like n
that's I'm not really people thought you
mean yeah I don't know if you didn't
hear him talk yet if you never heard him
speak oh okay I could see that I mean
the ear thing is intimidating yeah the
face thing too a little bit I think once
my head got shaved people started
looking at me like what the [__] damn
when I saw you on social media through
them and I hadn't even like watched a
like I just saw videos of you like
punching [__] and just your content I
was like this guy's probably [__]
probably beat my ass and be mean to me
yeah D you're like the nicest guy ever
the vibe yeah um yeah cuz yeah they
associate you with you being in a
certain type of way and I'm like I I
think that's the complete opposite but I
don't know maybe it's a
I know maybe it's part of all of it who
knows I don't know you don't have a you
laughing dude cuz you're you're so
closed man no but seriously I think
that's one of them you're already so
like a deflector when you put the shades
on and you deflect that shit's [__]
fun took a big old us from the room dude
I did yeah I don't even know don't side
dude okay
well any did I say it okay cool what
about you Bart did I say say it can I
say enough that's the new I love how we
all just like let him marinate until we
see him doubt himself instead of trying
to save his ass it just like take it
take the floor go ahead Bart what do you
think like help me help me help me help
me help
me I don't know what mine is besides I
think like the kind of similar to Joe
where people they probably think I'm
crazy but then they meet me and I'm not
I'm actually like very introver maybe
that's it yeah people think I'm really
extroverted like I probably like to go
to all the events meet all the people do
all the crazy [__] um but I'm actually
really
introverted and um you're really
introverted I'm really
introverted and I actually don't even
like attention that much you you um you
actually don't like uh like being out
and socializing with people that you
don't know that's aren't your friends
that aren't your friends yeah and I
don't even like attention like like my
ideal would be maybe I wrote movies and
not be the actor but I like I like doing
creative [__] so I think like in the
beginning it was more of a necessity
where like me and Joe had ideas and we
just had to be the actors cuz it's like
a YouTube with such a
self-producing environment but I
actually don't even like attention or me
being on camera or whatever that much
like I would like this Dynamic even if
the cameras weren't here yeah you know
what I mean like I like I just like
[__] around being the boys um even if
there wasn't a camera but I think people
like they probably go oh this guy's been
online for how how long he must like
attention but it's more that's more of
like a what is the word like [__]
something to the mean to the me me to an
end mean to it means to an end it's more
of like a mean to an end versus people
want like someone like Tim he wants to
be famous he wants to be whatever for me
it was like the publicity and the fame
and being on camera and all that stuff
is just part of the process of or more
of like an afterthought of me doing the
stuff that I do like uh yeah it's almost
like someone imagine someone really
likes standup and they just want to keep
doing standup but then they blow the
[__] up and their faces on billboards
they didn't really like that part it's
just because they did stand up so much
that they that became part of the like
the result the funny thing is Bart keeps
getting more and more followers on
Instagram and he's like oh my God I get
more [__] detention
dud yeah the
success I can see that I'm actually like
kind of like I like what are the things
that you like to do that you
enjoy what do you mean oh because you
said that um you don't like to be in the
thing but what are the things that you
actually enjoy doing that you or like in
this world or just in my life yeah
you're or or in work world like your oh
work world I like doing funny [__] and I
like doing creative projects okay yeah I
really enjoy that to be responsible for
the product but not be the product yeah
like even when me and Joe's like uh if
we could find it but it's like our old
school MMA like DVD at our our one of
our first fights in that school me and
Joel are already [__] around everyone
has like like a serious like this is my
first my third stripe test and whatever
and then me and jar like we don't know
we don't know if anyone ever going to
see this DVD or anything like that my
MMA gloves has two happy faces on it
like it's just already has already been
like that I just like like [__]
around you know this is the MMA gym when
you met like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
like we have a DVD from like
200 probably four or some [__] I I got
it somewhere yeah you got to find it and
we've been [__] around since then and
I I just enjoy the [__] around the
creative part and having a good time and
not so much like the the fame part of it
and then cuz I think think for me like I
don't get my energy drained from from
close friends it gets drained when I'm
like being out in public and doing stuff
like that's that's a real introvert yeah
like so if you invited me to a party I
almost rather go like can we grab dinner
before something
yeah yeah who are the
extroverts I am okay you are you
extrovert I don't know no I'm not you're
not extra you throw parties all the time
I know but I it's because I like other
people to have a good time like I'm not
really you like hosting yeah I love I
love being like I like being responsible
for the thing I don't like to be the
thing I don't always like to be this
before so during college times we would
throw a bunch of parties at my house M
and then the party would go on and I
would just go in my room and go to sleep
what cuz I know people I know people
just excuse themselves out and I know my
other roommate and the other people will
stick around until 1 or 2 a.m. excuse
themselves out no I mean I think even I
would rather do that but I think for for
me it's like I I try to turn the battery
up so high so that I'm always like being
engaging and entertaining and but the
truth in the course it's like [__] I
don't want to say something stupid or do
something dumb or like I'm very worried
normally about people not having a good
time like if you even one to one for cuz
I was one of the first of the homies to
move out so I had my own space so it
became the like default Party Place yeah
yeah yeah and then so we packed it with
fun like 19-year-old [__] like drinks
hookah [__] whatever you know and
then I was like cool everyone come and
then and then I just go and I close the
door everyone's good all right hopefully
I think I'm both you think you're both
oh enjoy okay cuz I like I enjoy that
too but I'm I'm not like I love hosting
people and I love making people have a
good time but I'm not like [__] I don't
want to be here but I also love not
being around people and just having my
own time and like just being private in
my house home body somebody's like we're
throwing a party I love having a good
excuse of why I can't go mhm I really do
but sometimes you want to go I one of my
homies explained this well to me I'm
like super extrovert if people come to
me you know what I mean like if homies
are coming like to my spot or whatever
and I'm hosting I'm like I I can give
you all the
energy everything you need but if I got
to go out I'm like I'd rather be
introvert cuz I'm like a homebody yeah
I'm same way yeah yeah yeah there is a
thing with like hosting it's more like
yeah you want them to have a good time
and I want to give you the thing but if
you go you feel like maybe you're taking
their energy like it's like you maybe
you owe them a thing EXT just means like
you like charging with people and an
introvert just means like you need to
isolate and that's how you reach that's
not my definition but that's what it
means just joking that's what it means
so you don't want you say wrong anymore
wrong that's not my definition I'm more
PC now I I don't want to say wrong
because it was hurtful
Anthony you said
God damn you know what's different too
is like you know the idea when you have
to go to a place and you know you're not
going to know anybody but you know that
in order to perform correctly you have
to meet people and like talk like if a
brand hooks you up with like going to a
thing to represent or something or just
going to a new party it's like I kind of
hate those too I I I hate those but I
also know that I will do very well
because I have to turn it on but it's
the energy it takes to turn it on I'm
afraid of that damn I'm afraid of the
feeling of like walking in a room and
just
going hey what's up man how you doing
yeah it's that feeling of like I know
I'm not going to fail but I know it's
going to be a lot of work yeah after
after conventions or [__] cons or all
those things whatever after I'm done
with those I'm
like yeah it's deadly yeah and then you
go to like [__] the most closest Yard
House to the
place yeah but how many people are you
meeting day you're meeting like tons of
people though yeah but whatever those
Expo whatever shows playlist whatever
Vicon any of those afterwards I'm
like that's a whole new topic but this
is good that's like a that's like a 100
people you're talking to I have a
completely opposite reaction that's a
lot bro what's that one I don't feel
like oh I feel fired up like we're ready
for war like after the convention I'm
just like I could take on anybody I feel
like fully charged I'm like at the pizza
place like [__] yeah aggressive
yeah the the thing that I hear over and
over from introverts is like I feel like
you guys put a lot of thought and like
weight and and and I think it it's it's
worrying like before the event and and
like it takes a lot of energy out of you
so like you have to kind of premeditate
how you conserve it and how you exercise
that right whereas like I think
extroverts are more like ooh what's
going to happen today you know and just
like hey hey hey hey who's oh wow and
you're who oh [__] and by the end of it
you're like I made so many [__]
friends today like I have like a
thousand new friends and like [__] I
have a thousand new more people to start
like [__] hanging out with and
talking to and then like and then at the
end of it you're just like wow that was
so cool and then you start like I got
new people to call up and hang with and
whatever and then I think the difference
might be at least for me is like you
don't
adjust and strategize for these people
you see who's entertaining to you so
you're like I like you you're
entertaining you're boring I don't want
to talk to you you're you're
entertaining you're engaging you're
energizing me I like you you I probably
have to deal with you but what's
interesting about you uh you're kind of
boring me still I'm going to find a way
to entertain myself with you and make
you interesting and then it's just kind
of that's I think that's very similar to
like what a lot of introvert I mean
extroverts so do you feel anything if
like let's say you're cold talking to
someone that you're just sitting there
and then you say like something like oh
coffee huh and then they just go mhm you
feel nothing at all no I just go like oh
you're
weird that's budy and just move on to
the next person to the next for for me
it's like I don't need any more new
friends at all yeah and then so when uh
when someone earns my friendship or
someone has something that I'm like wow
that's really cool then I I invest like
a lot of my energy and oh this this
person's really different but otherwise
I'm like cuz I think my I only have so
much energy so I want I rather save it
for the people I already know yeah so I
don't want I don't want to meet
strangers I don't want to invest any
energy in any other people I don't need
any more of new friends at all unless
like just through life you're like oh
you know what that guy's actually really
really cool I do want to MH yeah yeah I
I I don't think it's um actually that
like I I think it's more um superficial
for extroverts it's not actually it's
not oh it doesn't affect us emotionally
so it's more like an entertainment thing
so you come in and you're like like
let's say I have an empty battery
because I've been home alone for so long
and I'm just like o I can't wait to
charge up so I'm an energy vampire so
I'm going up and I'm like you're [__]
fun to talk to and then now I'm getting
my energy and I'm like I got as much as
I want from you now who's the next
person
next person and now at the end I'm like
charged up and I'm like and on top of
that I have this like roll deck of phone
numbers of Now new people I can be
entertained by I see and it sounds kind
of [__] up but I think it's like makes
sense it doesn't really affect us until
you make a authentic friendship for a
long time and then they can affect you
but it's not [__] up because those
other people might be extroverts too
true and then you're just talking all
day and you're like cool and you walk
away defin official to this I have a
question for introverts like uh if you
talk to somebody how do you know like if
you try to get to know somebody like at
an event or like a party or just how do
you know when to be like oh I shouldn't
just talk to one person for two
hours right I I want to do that yeah me
too I prefer that as well I'd rather
have a deep strong connection it feels
better then just do that or introvert no
but then like sometimes like I event or
whatever you're supposed to for like a
work event you're supposed to like om
meet like well then you just got to put
on a different hat if you you're
supposed to do it because of what you're
probably trying to progress some sort of
other work thing then you don't think
about it like a social party you think
about it like a work thing okay but how
do you how do you but sometimes you meet
a person you're like oh this person is
really cool I really want to talk to you
for like an hour 2 hours but then how do
you exit that conversation you know what
I mean or if that person's like you say
something like hey so sorry I don't want
to cut this short can I get your IG
handle or cont or whatever so let's
let's meet up you want to link for
coffee cuz you got to go talk to
somebody else okay but then you can't do
that but if you can you do that to like
seven other people yeah
oh yeah but then but then they're still
there you said by and then they're still
there no they under they also understand
that for networking too you have to go
talk to other people as well okay well
I'm learning well you can't go like this
you can't do this [__] man you can't you
can't trying to ask question you can't
do it like this where it's like hey it
was a really nice song make dry got to
go right now hey what's up man like you
can't be the next person right next door
hey I got I got I got a stomach I really
got to take a [__] so nice talk hey
what's up dude hey what are you do where
you
from that's what I'm saying you don't do
that you got at
Le this is the right way to pretend to
get a coffee pretend to go to the
bathroom like mix it up a little bit go
over there yeah you do that I do that
thing I go thank you so much I really
got to
go
that's
[Music]
funny